-Qui n'a pas craqué un jour
sous la pression
ou sous la fatigue ?
Pour mon invité, ça s'est produit
en février 2020, dans l'hémicycle.
Il en parle aujourd'hui sans tabou
et porte un regard lucide
sur ses débuts à l'Assemblée.
Générique
...
-Bonjour, Nicolas Turquois.
-Bonjour.
-On vous a confié un rôle important
en 2020,
sur la 1re réforme des retraites,
vous étiez corapporteur
de ce texte,
vous le défendiez
dans l'hémicycle.
Au début,
tout se passe bien pour vous,
puis, au fil du temps,
une partie de l'opposition
a joué la carte
de l'obstruction,
les séances ont traîné en longueur,
la tension est montée
petit à petit
jusqu'à un moment fatidique
qu'on va revivre en images.
*-Voici une citation
que je n'avais pas prévue.
Certains parmi vous ont déclaré :
"La République, c'est moi",
mais la République,
c'est nous, et vous êtes rien.
Acclamations
...
-Monsieur le ministre...
-Alors, cette séquence
a beaucoup tourné
sur les réseaux, à l'époque,
mais aussi dans les JT.
Qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé,
ce jour-là ?
Vous avez craqué ?
-Oui, on peut dire ça comme ça.
Vous êtes...
Quand vous êtes rapporteur du texte,
et c'était pas n'importe quel texte,
vous devez répondre,
vous devez argumenter
à chaque amendement de la majorité,
de l'opposition, et donner la raison
de votre avis favorable
ou défavorable en fonction
de ce qui s'est passé en commission.
Sachant qu'avant la séance
de l'hémicycle, il y a eu,
je crois, deux semaines, au moins,
en commission, où vous faites
le même travail avec des gens
qui ont plus une spécialisation
sur le sujet.
Donc s'accumule...
S'accumule de la fatigue,
s'accumule de la tension,
Quand vous êtes à l'hémicycle,
vous pouvez sortir
pour un café.
Quand vous êtes au banc,
vous répondez en permanence
sur tout.
-Défendre le texte,
ne pas sortir.
-De mémoire,
il y avait deux séries d'amendements
qui allaient se succéder
de 300 amendements chacune ou 400,
enfin, plusieurs centaines,
chacune proposait de décaler
l'âge d'application de six mois,
des mesures,
des dates d'application de six mois.
Donc, théoriquement, il aurait fallu
que je réponde à chacun
des amendements en disant pourquoi
j'étais contre six mois plus tard
et six mois plus tard.
Donc la fatigue, plus ce côté
extrêmement dur, physiquement
et psychologiquement...
-Vous étiez privé
de famille
pendant ce temps.
Je crois que votre famille
était là, ce jour.
-Elle était présente quelques...
Deux heures avant.
Elle venait me voir,
car elle m'avait pas vu
en 15 jours, 3 semaines,
donc elle était là.
Elle n'était plus là
quand j'ai dit ça.
Elle était là 2 heures avant
et je devais les retrouver
à l'issue de cette séance.
-Quand vous prononcez cette phrase,
vous vous dites quoi ?
"Là, j'ai commis une erreur" ?
-Aussitôt.
-Vous savez ?
-Vous vous dites aussitôt :
"J'ai fait... J'ai fait...
J'ai fait une erreur."
Puis, vous vous excu...
Je crois que je m'excuse
5 minutes après,
mais c'est trop tard, la machine...
-C'est comme un burn-out ?
Il soupire.
-Je le...
Je l'analyse pas spécifiquement,
il y avait
une très grande tension,
il y avait...
Il y avait un côté qui est très dur
physiquement, il fait chaud,
les oppositions étaient
juste derrière moi
physiquement, donc ça a un effet...
C'est... C'est la goutte...
Le supplice chinois,
la goutte qui tombe en permanence.
Une de plus ne fait pas grand-chose,
mais l'accumulation
fait qu'on explose.
-Il y a eu cet épisode,
mais plus globalement,
tout le début de votre 1er mandat
a été compliqué,
vous ne vous en cachez pas.
Vous avez eu un peu de mal
à trouver votre place,
à comprendre votre rôle.
-J'ai eu du mal
à trouver ma place à l'hémicycle.
On doit être sur le terrain,
dans sa circonscription
et c'est la même chose
qu'être un élu local,
sauf qu'il faut faire
du relationnel, aller voir les gens,
répondre...
-Ca se passait bien ?
-Ca se passait bien,
c'est comme être maire,
mais en version...
En version XXL.
-Quel était le problème
dans l'hémicycle ?
-A l'hémicycle, vous arrivez,
quand vous êtes élu député,
avec l'image que vous vous faites
d'un député et cette image,
c'est celle du député à l'hémicycle.
Il m'a fallu du temps
pour comprendre que le sujet,
il fallait se spécialiser
et ne pas parler sur tout,
comme une discussion de comptoir,
et que le travail principal
était la commission.
On se spécialise,
on crée une relation
avec notamment
le ou les ministres en charge,
et là, vous faites passer des idées,
mais au début, à l'hémicycle,
il y a...
Vous aviez un certain nombre
de collègues qui ont peut-être plus
de bagou, plus d'ambition,
plus de facilité et on pense :
"A quoi je sers ?"
-Vous vous êtes posé
cette question.
Rétrospectivement,
c'est intéressant de réécouter
la réaction que vous avez eue
le soir
de votre élection en 2017,
il y avait un côté prémonitoire.
*-Je commence à comprendre
ce qui va se passer,
la révolution.
*-Quelle révolution ?
*-Bah, euh, dans ma vie personnelle,
dans ma vie professionnelle,
dans l'organisation du quotidien.
Les prochaines semaines
vont sûrement être avec beaucoup
de changements.
-Une 1re réaction surprenante.
D'habitude, on est dans la joie.
Vous, on vous sent inquiet.
Pourquoi ?
-Eh bien...
Il y a eu plusieurs sujets, mais...
Avant le 1er... Quand il y a...
A l'issue du 1er tour,
je me suis dit :
"C'est possible que je sois élu."
Je suis agriculteur, à la base.
Vous embauchez pas
des gens
au cas où vous seriez élu,
donc de se dire :
"Comment ça va se passer ?"
-Comment gérer l'exploitation
en étant député ?
-Je suis...
J'ai une famille.
J'avais des enfants,
des grands ados,
des ados et des grands ados
et de dire :
"Mais du jour au lendemain,
"je pars vers un monde nouveau."
Et puis,
cette découverte de la politique
et cette appréhension
du côté dur de la politique,
qu'on voit, des fois,
au niveau local.
Je pense que j'ai vu assez tôt
les défis, même si je les mesurais
pas encore à ce moment-là
dans leur ampleur,
mais j'ai vu assez tôt
que ça allait être compliqué.
-On va s'intéresser
à vos premiers pas en politique.
On s'intéresse
à ce qui peut déclencher
l'engagement
en politique.
Si on regarde votre parcours,
vous reprenez l'exploitation
de vos parents en 2000,
et un an plus tard, vous êtes élu
maire délégué
de votre petit village.
Est-ce que les 2 sont liés ?
Il faut y voir...
-Vous allez vite.
Un an plus tard,
je suis élu conseiller municipal.
C'est un peu plus tard
que j'ai été élu maire délégué,
mais je suis issu de la campagne,
donc revenir à la campagne
n'étais pas un problème pour moi.
Avec mon épouse, nous sommes
ingénieurs et elle est...
-Ingénieurs agronomes.
-Exactement.
Elle était de la ville et me dit :
"Je vais faire quoi
dans ton village avec ton projet ?
"J'ai envie d'un métier
qui corresponde à ma formation."
Je me suis dit que ce village
dans lequel j'avais toujours vécu
était assez âgé, par la population,
assez...
Sans trop de vie, et donc
qu'il fallait que je m'y investisse
pour que ma femme, mes enfants,
y trouvent
pleine satisfaction.
-Vous vous engagez
en politique pour votre famille,
vos proches.
Vous êtes élu conseiller municipal,
puis maire délégué du village,
responsable départemental
du MoDem, puis député.
Aujourd'hui,
votre vie est consacrée
à la politique,
mais vous avez voulu garder un pied
dans votre exploitation.
-Oui, assurément.
D'abord...
-Vous avez pas lâché
le...
-J'y suis toujours.
Je reste agriculteur, même si
j'ai évidemment pris de la distance.
Je participe surtout
aux travaux l'été,
je suis la gestion
au fur et à mesure de l'année.
Là, on me voit avec des échasses.
Pourquoi ?
Sûrement pour prendre de
la hauteur
en politique.
Non, c'est...
Je fais des productions en serre.
On accroche les cultures
à hauteur,
certaines cultures sous serre.
Mais c'est quelque chose
que j'aime profondément.
-Il y a un risque
de se déconnecter un peu du terrain,
de la réalité de la vie des Français
quand on est élu ?
-Clairement.
-Il faut rester
dans le milieu professionnel ?
-Déjà, j'aime mon métier,
mais je suis persuadé, je le vois,
j'ai l'impression de le voir
avec d'autres,
qu'on perd un contact
avec une certaine forme de réalité.
D'avoir été ou d'être
n'est pas la même chose.
Là, sur les sujets agricoles,
être toujours pleinement impliqué
dans les sujets agricoles me permet
d'avoir un regard,
une expertise, qui n'est pas la même
que si j'y avais été il y a 5 ans,
si je n'y étais plus depuis 5 ans.
Ca, c'est quelque chose
auquel je tiens.
Et puis,
vous reprenez pas le métier
d'agriculteur comme un autre métier.
Ma fonction de député peut s'arrêter
plus brutalement que prévu.
-Dans cinq ans.
-Et donc, je...
-C'est une forme de sécurité
pour vous ?
-Aussi.
-C'est l'heure de notre quiz.
Je vous explique le principe,
c'est assez simple.
Je vais lire le début d'une phrase
et c'est à vous de la compléter.
On y va ?
-On y va.
-C'est parti.
"Sur les questions
"d'agriculture"
- on en parlait à l'instant -
"la plupart des députés..."
-N'y connaissent rien.
-C'est votre constat ?
-Ils y sont sensibles,
mais l'expertise
est assez faible.
Elle est plutôt imagée,
l'image d'une agriculture
un petit peu dépassée, souvent.
-Vous-même, on vous a entendu un peu
sur la question,
mais ce n'est pas votre spécialité.
-Au tout début, j'étais vraiment
sur les questions agricoles
et j'ai eu l'impression
que mes collègues me filaient
tous les sujets agricoles,
d'être cornérisé
sur le sujet.
-Si vous le connaissez,
c'est bien.
-Oui,
mais j'ai envie de parler
d'agriculture, mais pas uniquement.
Le sujet des retraites
a été celui qui m'a tourné
vers le champ social
et c'est un sujet
que j'ai aimé.
Donc l'agriculture,
mais pas que.
-"A chaque fois
"que François Ruffin
prend la parole..."
-Il m'énerve.
Rires
-Lui en particulier
ou sa façon de s'opposer ?
-C'était sa façon de faire,
notamment au premier mandat.
Il a changé.
-Je ne l'ai pas choisi par hasard.
Il a été vraiment très présent
pendant le débat des retraites
et parfois, je peux comprendre
qu'il vous ait agacé,
il cherchait
la petite bête...
-Suite à ma sortie de route
que vous avez retransmise,
quelques mois plus tard,
il l'a rediffusée sur les réseaux.
-Vous lui en avez voulu ?
-Oui !
Ce n'est pas que moi.
C'est moi, ma famille,
mes collaborateurs,
et c'est des méthodes
qui sont inacceptables.
-Vous dites qu'il a changé ?
-Dans son expression.
Je l'ai entendu l'autre jour.
Même si je ne partageais pas
les arguments de fond,
je trouvais que la forme
pouvait amener à...
-A un échange ?
-A un échange.
-Peut-être moins possible avant ?
-Oui.
-Dernière phrase :
"A l'Assemblée,
"pour survivre, il faut..."
-Il faut s'investir
dans des sujets...
...précis, il faut...
Il faut gagner en expertise.
Il y a des parlementaires
qui ne sont pas de mon groupe...
Ils peuvent l'être,
de la majorité ou pas,
mais qui ont une vraie analyse
approfondie des sujets,
vous avez envie d'écouter,
ça apporte quelque chose,
un éclairage différent,
mais qui vous fait progresser.
Donc, pour survivre,
il faut être reconnu.
-On l'a vu,
la phase d'apprentissage
a été douloureuse
dans le 1er mandat
de député.
Vous êtes pas le seul
à avoir vécu ça.
Vous pensez
que ça pourrait être évité
avec une forme de formation
pour un député
en début de mandat
ou chacun doit se forger
son expérience ?
-Je crois... En tout cas,
au sein de mon groupe, le MoDem,
j'essaye, avec d'autres,
vis-à-vis des nouveaux députés,
de leur donner des clés
pour qu'ils se sentent
plus à l'aise,
car il faut se protéger,
se protéger pour sa vie privée,
dans son rythme de travail.
Quand on arrive à se protéger,
physiquement, psychologiquement,
on fait un bon député.
Avoir une forme de bienveillance
avec nos nouveaux collègues
permet d'éviter
en partie ce que j'ai pu ressentir
et que d'autres ont ressenti
il y a 5 ans.
-Merci beaucoup
d'être venu.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...